Question should I have my amalgam fillings removed and replaced with composite fillings is composite okay or just as bad
Composite is acceptable and it is not just as bad. So your amalgam fillings, your silver fillings are bad. They're very bad.
They leach into your body and into your mouth and you will swallow that mercury. Now if you had perfectly healthy gut in a perfect world, you'd probably deposit that into your toilet. You don't have
absorption sites for mercury. However, the fact is is that everybody has some level of leach gut and you will absorb that and it's going to cause problems.
So if a person has a diagnosis of cancer, should they have their amalgam fillings out? My answer to that is if they're healthy enough.
So and it also depends on the level of dentistry that's going to be involved in removing it. I just have three small fillings. I went to a biological dentist who's going to do it the right way. Use a rubber dam, have a mercury vacuum, use a nasal cannula, have something over my nose, so not breathing in the gasification of that filling what he's drilling it out.
So he's doing everything right and he said it's going to be fairly easy, removal and replacement. Then the answer be yes, but you also have to ask, am I healthy enough right now? If more I'm going to chemo, I've really been sick that I'd say no, wait. If no, I'm feeling great. And I'd say yes, go for it.
However, if the answer to those questions were, oh, I got mercury in all my teeth and it's just horrible. It's going to be this major, major dental intervention to deal with this.
I don't know, sometimes it's better to leave sleepy, like a giant's lie. It's, it's difficult. I've had patients with cancer that literally their teeth are just filled with mercury. I mean, literally should probably have all their tea tree moved and just go with dentures.
That would be the safest and healthiest way to deal with things. The problem was, I remember that patient, they were so ill when they came to see me.
They would have been able to tolerate any intervention at that time. So you have to weigh those factors out. It's never ever good to have mercury in your mouth. You always want to get your mercury fillings removed.
So, but you got to weigh out the level of intervention that's going to be necessary in that process and the current level of health.
And I made caveat 10 that you're going to a biological dentist who's going to do it the right way. The worst thing you could do is go to your dentist. He said he could just remove it. He told me it's no big deal. He's just going to remove it.
It is a big deal. You have to do it right. You have to go to a biological dentist that's going to use a rubber dam that's going to use a mercury vacuum. It's going to use a nasal cannula. It's going to block your nasal passages that you're not going to breathe it in.
And they're going to do things correctly and they take it seriously. So otherwise you don't do anything with any other dentist.